welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course not david pakman David
we'll be back tomorrow he's travelling
today I'm Benjamin Dixon host of the
Benjamin Dixon show but you already knew
that if you've been listening and
watching this show so far so let's just
jump right into it one thing that the
Republican Party has been shamelessly
doing is rejecting any institutional
norms that they otherwise would observe
and that's a whole lot of words it's
basically say that they're bending the
rules in their favor even when they use
the rules in their favor right this is
what they're doing and for the first
time in history the records for a
Supreme Court justice that are to be
released to be reviewed by senators so
that they can make their decision on
this this this nominee rather these
records are being filtered through by a
Republican operative instead of the
National Archives Brett Kavanaugh is now
being protected by Republican a
Republican attorney who was an operative
instead of all of his records being
released they are releasing a specific
set of Records during a very narrow time
frame of his service his previous
service I want to bring up an article a
quote for you now this is from the New
Republic Chuck Grassley the Iowa
Republican senator who chairs the Senate
Judiciary Committee sent a letter
notifying Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
last week that he was quote not going to
put American taxpayers on the hook by
seeking Cavanaugh's records from his
time as Bush's staff secretary he will
still sin still request records from his
recoving all served as in the White
House counsel's office it's unlikely
that those records Grassley wrote would
provide any meaningful insight into how
Kavanaugh would perform his judicial
duties if confirmed to the Supreme Court
now I mean at face value that is absurd
first of all he's saying that we're not
gonna put American taxpayers on the hook
listen we could spend money on
everything else we just gave me 1.5
trillion dollar giveaway one trillion
dollar giveaway to the wealthiest people
in the country I'm sure that we can
afford a few million dollars to make
sure that we get all of the records for
this nominee so that we can examine
everything
he did particularly in a time that's
most significant to American history we
are literally engaged in Wars right now
two presidents later that were initiated
during Cavanaugh's time right so we need
to time serving for the president so we
need to see these records we need to see
what he believed what he said how he
explained things and it goes beyond that
so the excuse is is the excuse that we
won't put America's taxpayer dollars on
the hook is is patently absurd but then
the second part that it doesn't tell us
anything meaningful about how he was
served is also patently ridiculous but
again like I said at the beginning of
this segment
Republicans have absolutely no problem
rejecting institutional norms that they
otherwise would use in their favor let's
go to the next quote so we can deepen
this a little more this is from Senate
Majority Leader and this is what he said
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer he
said the Republican majority has cast
aside democratic wishes for openness and
transparency and has made a partisan
request for only a small subset of
George cabin halls records it is such a
break from precedent that you have to
wonder what are Republicans hiding about
Judge Kevin Hall's records and that's
the only thing that you can conclude is
that Republicans are hiding something of
course they're hiding something look at
the time frame that they're hiding it
from let's go to the next quote because
this really just puts it all together
this is what they're hiding actually
this is the quote from the New Republic
there doesn't appear to be any
reasonable justification to keep those
documents out of the public's eyes
before Cavanaugh's confirmation vote
other than the concerns that you might
find something that could prevent it the
next quote is the one that I won't write
here as staff secretary from 2003 to
2006 Cavanaugh would have been well
placed to weigh in on some of the Bush
administration's most significant
moments including the Iraq war and it's
aftermath
the Abu Ghraib scandal and other torture
related policies the reauthorization of
the Patriot Act the federal
partial-birth abortion
and more according to the New Republic
these are critical issues this is not
just a way of slowing down the process
these are critical issues that we can
get insight into how this man actually
thinks and how he is going to adjudicate
it on the bench this this tells us who
he is as a individual yes but more
specifically it tells us who he is with
regard to some of the most critical
issues of our day we are literally
engaged in those conflicts to today and
he was there in 2003 in a position of
influence where he could have given some
statements of substance that shine
insight into who he is and how he thinks
and yet chuck grassley of the republican
party
doesn't think there's anything there
this is this is absurd and of course
that is the talking point that is now
being reverberating through their echo
chamber all day long today all day long
going forward they're gonna say there's
nothing there
that's nothing important we have enough
records to determine who he is the fact
of the matter is why who in in what way
I don't even have the words for it in
what way would any reasonable human
being look at the time period in which
we instituted we initiated
generation-long Wars and this guy has
had input into it what reasonable human
being would not be interested in it you
want to know who conservatives
Republicans who are more interested in
how they could win a fight they're more
interested in how they could win a
Facebook argument than they are putting
someone qualified on the bench that's
all this is about all this is about is
scoring points for their red team for
the red team this is all they care about
and ultimately the the other side of
that coin is not only do they just want
to win facebook arguments for their
football team the red team they also
want to make sure that they get anybody
if they don't care how he rules on any
other issue so long as they get someone
who would be a defining vote in
overturning Roe vs. Wade
and we have the opportunity to actually
see what caliber of a person we're
putting on the bench for the next thirty
years and all they care about is making
sure that they could score some points
for their side